You're nice, baby.
Thanks.
Hello!
Hey!
Laura, this is Joanna, my wife.
Hi, nice to meet you.
Laura is the new designer that we've been working with.
Did you just say new?
I've been here like three months.
You didn't tell me anything about her before tonight.
'Cause it makes you like this, baby.
I mean, seriously, did you think that I just wouldn't notice?
You two already slept together?
There's nothing going on.
Is she going to Philadelphia with you and Andy tomorrow?
Laura's just someone I work with.
Michael, it'd kill you if you knew how much I knew about you.
Hey.
Joanna.
Alex, what are you doing here?
I have some work here.
I can't believe this.
And I leave tomorrow.
Do you have time for me now?
Yeah.
Yeah, sure.
I had no idea you were seeing someone in New York.
Oh, no. We're just good friends.
Remind me why it didn't work.
Geography.
What are you drinking?
Scotch.
And timing.
I'd love another drink.
Okay.
Just not here.
Are you getting a divorce?
No.
So, have you ever been cheated on?
I've never told him about us.
Why? Would he be angry?
Have you thought about what he might be doing right now?
Michael isn't doing anything.
He could be thinking the same thing about you.